Joe Thomas NFL Network analyst you can
follow him on Twitter at Joe Thomas 73
and see Joe every Thursday on NFL
Network NFL gameday kickoff that starts
at six Eastern leading into the Thursday
night game this week Bucs
in the Panthers that's exclusively on
the NFL Network I don't know if this is
a must-win situation for the Panthers
but it's pretty close I try not to use
that too often but it feels like in that
division you can't afford to lose this
one against the Tampa Bay Buccaneers Joe
joins us now is it a must-win situation
for the Panthers Thursday night Joe I
believe it is only 2 out of 12 teams
made the playoffs last year that started
Owen - and you look at that NFC South
Division the Saints looking pretty good
we kind of expect that they're gonna
make the playoffs this year and I'm not
exactly sure that a wild-card team is
going to come out of the NFC South this
year so to fall behind Owen - for the
Panthers would be a little bit more of
what we saw from them at the end of last
season and they definitely don't want to
be the same team that they were to
finish the season last year I have
concerns about how they use Christian
McCaffrey because it doesn't feel like
Cam is a hundred percent and it feels
like you know when all else fails just
give the ball or throw the ball -
Christian McCaffrey
how concerned would you be of overuse of
Christian McCaffrey we got to be a
little concerned he had almost 30
touches last week and the reason they
keep giving him the football is because
he seems to be their only big-time
playmaker on offense especially as cam
can't really run the football right now
like he usually does because of that
foot injury that he got in the preseason
and they're trying to take some hits off
of him but for a guy that's not a huge
player physically like Christian
McCaffrey to get 30 touches is not
exactly sustainable for the long term
you know he's done a great job of
avoiding injury so far in his career but
you got to be a little concerned if
that's all you have and that's always
going to be your safety valve on offense
because it is a physical sport in the
NFL and you're not thinking that this is
a guy that can survive that many touches
week in and week out why did the NFL
allow why did the game officials allow
Odell
back him to wear that watch in the game
what's a good question I think Odell
came out and said he's read the rules
and you're allowed to wear jewelry and I
guess the refs deemed it jewelry because
it's not exactly something they see on a
daily basis seeing guys come out wearing
watches since not exactly a requisite
part of your uniform so maybe they were
just thinking now we'll let it slide
because we can kind of see that it's
probably jewelry yeah but it's a watch
and now you have something hard that
you're wearing there's a safety issue
here it's not like wearing a knee brace
or a necklace
hey I'm not I'm not arguing for wearing
a watch I can't see that wearing a watch
can help you in any manner on a football
field other than maybe looking good when
it's all said and done and your
touchdown pictures but clearly this is
kind of a gray area that refs probably
never encountered before since like I
mentioned watches are not exactly part
of catching or throwing a football or
blocking even so this might be something
that we'll see the NFL look into and
obviously hey Odell doesn't want it to
be a storyline but it is when you wear a
$200,000 watch on a Sunday okay even if
he's wearing a Timex it still doesn't
matter how much it costs but if you're
his teammate are you bothered by this I
would say if you're his teammate you're
thinking just take the watch off like
why does it matter it's not helping you
catch the football it's not helping you
run faster run better routes so if it
becomes a distraction if it becomes
something that we have to talk about if
it's not helping you become a better
football player let's just do the easy
thing and just not wear it
would it bother you though would you say
something to him if you were playing
well I think the first week I people
probably didn't notice not honestly I
didn't really notice until it became a
big deal on social media because it is a
nice looking watch it kind of blends in
with the Jersey he is right it doesn't
look really nice but once you find out
that it costs more than most people's
house then you're thinking wow that
seems a little unnecessary and then you
dig into the rules
it's kind of this gray area well it is a
hard object but you're allowed to wear
jewelry so is it allowed isn't it
allowed and then it just becomes a
distraction in Odell throughout his
career when he was with the Giants had a
lot of distractions and they were not
related to his performance on the field
but I think he would be smart and maybe
his teammates might nudge him in the
right direction of hey why don't we just
turn over a new leaf you're in Cleveland
and just try to avoid doing the things
that don't help us win on Sunday that we
have to talk about Sunday after the game
that have nothing to do with football
yeah I know where during warmups if you
want to but not during the game it's
like you go this is what I am concerned
about with the Browns I got a guy who's
never been a head coach and I got Odell
there and you know I got guys who were
brands now i-i-i don't have high
expectations for the Browns I don't have
them making the playoffs and this isn't
an overreaction to week one I just think
it's hard to piece it all together and
you know they got blown out at home by
Tennessee and that offensive line looks
spotty right now for me Joe if I'm a
Browns fan what did you see that it it
concerns you more not just a week one
overreaction but this is something to
keep an eye on the rest of the season
the thing that concerned me was the
penalties they had 18 10 of these for
almost 200 yards and they're a team that
talked all training-camp about
discipline and accountability and we're
going to be a different Browns team
Freddie kitchens is a Bill Parcells
disciple he's a guy that believes and
toughness and then you go out and you
have that many mistakes and you have
that much sloppiness it looked like a
team that hadn't played together before
which they were not a team that really
has played together they've added a lot
of pieces and that's why they were so
hyped and that's why everyone was so
excited about this season but now that
week one they look like they've they
were inexperienced and they got beaten
by a Titan team that didn't have as much
talent but had played together before
and had that experience so I think
moving forward they got to prove that
yes we have all these talented pieces
but also yes we can play together and
play football because football is a team
sport and the best teams win the bet
teams that play together so that's going
to be their goal going into the Monday
night game against the Jets I brought up
the commissioners exempt list we've seen
it a couple of times most notably with
Adrian Peterson I don't know if Antonio
Brown ends up on that commissioners
exempt list what are the players think
of the commissioners exempt list the
players probably don't like it overall
but I do think it is a good useful tool
for the NFL to be able to do something
with somebody while they at least go
through some of the investigation
obviously it's going to take a lot of
time for all of this stuff with Antonio
Brown to play out and that's what
happens with the legal system it's very
slow it takes a long time to find out
innocent or guilty and so Roger and the
NFL clearly they want to be able to
address something before the courts come
to a decision two maybe three years
later so I think the exemption list is
something that's reasonable put the guy
on there for the short term let the NFL
investigators at least find out if he's
clearly innocent or clearly guilty and
then at that point then they can decide
what they want to do in a short term
until the legal process kind of finds
its way through what's the weight what
do you weigh now that's kind of a
personal question
there was a few too many beverages
consumed when he barbecues eaten so I'm
actually trying to get back down a
little bit for my big Thursday night
football career here this fall so I'm
about 255 right now what do you mention
hopefully over 255 not working out as
much as I wanted to but you know what
I'll throw three plates on the bar today
and I'll give you an update
hey Joe the the camera adds 15 pounds so
right now you're about 270 I guess I'm
not eating until you've given me a
complex hey good to talk to you have fun
on Thursday night great to catch up with
you oh thanks a lot Dan I appreciate it
and that's Joe Thomas works for the NFL
Network and he'll be there Thursday
night NFL game day kickoff as you have
the Panthers against the Buccaneers for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on Direct
a stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]